any baby fever
i've already got it yeah i already got
it
from baby fever to fun in the oven
congrats are in order for jenna johnson
and val schmerkovsky the dancing with
the star pros are expecting the couple
announced on instagram jenna is pregnant
with their first child due in january
she posted a series of stunning pics
with val kissing and cradling her
growing baby bump
daddy
in the caption jenna gushed our biggest
dream come true yet
the mom-to-be continued to open up about
her pregnancy so far writing my heart
has grown beyond comprehension while
growing this little miracle inside of me
we can't wait to meet our precious angel
meanwhile the dad to be kept his
announcement simple posting a sonogram
and a heart emoji
and for val and jenna who got married in
2019 their love has always been on full
display
i'm in a great place i'm in love and i'm
very grateful for that
the couple opened up to e.t shortly
after tying the knot about their plans
to start a family
we want kids not right now
yeah we won't enjoy being married fresh
off newlywed bliss jenna has turned that
into a pregnancy glow
i'm really excited
back in april the duo celebrated jenna's
28th birthday in cabo an eyewitness
tells e.t jenna and val looked relaxed
and in love on their vacay where jenna
believes her baby was conceived our
insider spotted the pair lounging by the
pool quote she was glowing as he rubbed
her shoulders
a baby made in paradise sounds too
perfect val even told us in 2019 he's
open to having a big family as long as
jenna's down
that's a blessing you know and to have a
large family you and jenna gotta get on
if i'm sick
i know well jen look at jenna's physique
you know if she's ready to
give that up for for
a beautiful
pregnant physique i'm down she's
beautiful regardless so i'm in
[Music]
you